this is something that actually came out
of the comments on one of the previous
videos we did about birefringence and
somebody wanted to know whether double
rainbows were the same kind of effect
and so I thought I talked about rainbows
so really to explain this I need to do
an experiment I need to show you what a
rainbow actually is so I have here the
Sun and a raindrop not to scale I have
to say and so hopefully with these two
fine tools we should be able to
demonstrate the physics of rainbows if
you switch the lights out okay so if you
kind of come down to my level okay so if
you work your way around towards the
right there so kind of a little you can
see the little white dot that sort of
reflected off the back of our giant
raindrop there and as you go around you
will see that it kind of moves towards
the right so it kind of comes towards
you and then at some point suddenly it
turns colors so you'll see it go blue
green red and then disappear entirely
and the point is you're currently 42
degrees away from the direction that the
lights shining in from okay so what
we've got is we've got the light coming
in and as you can see as it passes
through this surface so it goes from one
medium to another the speed of light
changes which has this effect of
changing the direction that the lights
traveling in but the amount by which it
gets changed depends on the wavelength
of the light blue light gets bent a
little more than red light so you can
see that the blue light reaches the back
of the drop at a slightly different
point from the red light and then when
they get reflected back again and again
there's another bit of a fraction when
they come out the raindrop again and you
can see that basically the light the red
light at least in these extreme rays
ends up travelling slightly or a
slightly wider angle than the blue
that's when when you as you were panning
around the last light you saw was the
red light so you see just normal
reflection pretty much all the way
around to here and then when you're at
this last point to its last angle that
stuff can actually get through the drop
at all you first see blue light then you
see red light then you see nothing
further out at all of course that's not
what happens with the rainbow with a
rainbow what you have picture is you
have lots and lots of drops which means
there's always one at the right exactly
the right angle to send the red light
towards you or to send the blue light
towards you and so actually what you end
up seeing is that
remember this this at magic angle of
around 42 degrees anything that's around
42 degrees that this angle here between
the direction the sun rays are coming
from and the direction you're looking
from you'll end up seeing either red
light or a little bit further out you'll
see blue light that actually means that
rainbows actually are around right
that's actually this is circle of points
that are 42 degrees away from from this
line to the Sun but what actually
happens is that half of that circle is
typically below the horizon so that you
see like half a circle of the light and
so you'll end up just seeing the classic
kind of rainbow semicircle if you have
to be at this magic 42 degree angle how
come I can see a rainbow and Johnny
Smith five miles away can see a rainbow
because he's looking at difference at a
raindrop so he's still looking 42
degrees away from the Sun but from from
where he's standing he sees a completely
different set of raindrops that are all
doing exactly the same thing back toward
you so when I see a rainbow at my house
and you see a rainbow over at your house
we're actually seeing two different
rainbow you're seeing a different set of
raindrops that are causing the the
effect I mean obviously it's the same
Sun that's causing the effect and it's
the same physics but it's a different
set of raindrops reflecting it all back
to you yeah and the other thing you
noticed is that when you went beyond so
when you were looking at kind of closer
to the Sun sort of closer to straight
backwards and forwards so kind of when
you're looking at light just reflected
off the back of the raindrop you saw
basically white light and it's only when
you get to these these extreme angles
that you actually see the red and the
blue light and of course that's why if
you look at a picture of a rainbow
you'll always see that inside the
rainbow he's always brighter than
outside the rainbow core the inside the
rainbow you're seeing just mostly that
whitish light being reflected back it's
the sum of all the different colors
being reflected back to you so you see
it as white light then you reach this
edge of it where you're just about
seeing just those last few colors and
then when you go to wider angles still
you see nothing at all and that's why
the outside of the rainbow appears
darker than the inside of the rainbow I
thought you were holding about double
rainbows double rainbows we can do too
so double rainbows also again
classically understood going back at
least to as far as so Descartes did this
experiment again in the 17th century
lots of people who had a go at this and
what they realized is so if we go back
to our original picture for just a
second so what was happening here is the
light comes in gets refracted reflected
once off the back of the raindrop comes
back out refracted again in a double
rainbow
what hangs is the light takes a slightly
different path another picture you can
have the light coming in gets refracted
gets reflected once reflected twice and
then comes back out again and comes out
at a different angle from if it had just
undergone a single reflection at the
bank this is another way of making a
rainbow at a different angle so the
first way still works you can have
things the light coming in and get
reflected once and that'll give us a
rainbow at one angle or it can go in and
get reflected twice and then we end up
with a rainbow at two angles so you end
up with a picture like this so we've
still got the first rainbow here where
the lights coming in getting reflected
back to us just once off the back of the
raindrop and so we should see that the
colors spread blue to rid but there's a
second way that it can happen that it
can actually bounce twice around the
raindrop and take this rather more
complicated path and what you can see is
that actually the rainbow ends up being
reversed because of that second
reflection where the red light was
originally on the outside if you look
you had a second rainbow you'll see that
actually the color is inverted that the
the original rainbow the inner rainbow
goes from blue to red the second rainbow
goes from red to blue and in fact all
the effects are reversed so as we were
talking about before you see a brighter
light down here then you see a normal
rainbow for the other rainbow
everything's reversed so you see the
second rainbow and then you see brighter
light further away and so the famously
you see this thing called Alexander's
band which is the dark region in between
where there's no white light gets
reflected at all because in the first
rainbow it's all bending up down here
and from the second rainbow it's all
ending up up there it seems to me we
should see a double rainbow every time
and yet we only occasionally see a
double rainbow it really is because that
so what happens is that in the raindrop
most of the light just go straight
through only a little bit of it gets
reflected and so actually it's a very
inefficient process most of the light
just travels straight through the
raindrop a little bit of it gets
reflected of course if you want to
reflect it twice that means a little bit
gets reflected then then only a little
bit of the little bit gets reflected and
so the second rainbow is always much
fainter than the first so it is actually
always there and in fact a very
occasionally you can even see a third
rainbow which is even faint too still so
these other rainbows are always still
there but they're always much fainter so
if you can only just see the primary
rainbow you're not going to see the
secondary rainbow at all one it's always
when you have a really stonkingly bright
primary rainbow that you end up seeing
the secondary one
people often ask this question you know
don't you lose the magic of something by
actually understanding it you know by
actually understanding where a rainbow
comes from isn't it not beautiful
anymore but
you've explained it and it's all very
simple and trivial and of course he
doesn't write I mean you know I
understand the physics of rainbows but I
could still look go out and look at one
and say wow that's pretty so it really
didn't you know it doesn't have that
negative effect at all it's just it just
adds to the experience of seeing a
rainbow then not only does it look
beautiful but you actually understand
why it looks beautiful too